you know Beyonce's come a long way check
out this 2003 interview I'm older now
and I'm making a lot more of my own
decisions that was from MTV News which
is being shut down after 36 years we do
a lot of talking to people on the street
and people are in record stores yeah
remember Kurt loader well he's 78 now
back in 2021 he told me how the
groundbreaking news division began you
guys really were at one point the cool
kids I mean it was the way that a
generation got their news Mr President
the world is dying to know is it boxes
are briefs
you remember about first starting I
remember when we started doing MTD games
what are some of the moments that jump
out to you to meet Kurt Cobain breaking
that news Kurt Cobain the leader of One
of Iraq's most gifted and promising
bands Nirvana is Dead are there any
interviews that stick out to you we did
Prince once we get sunglasses on and it
just wouldn't take them off what you
need to know all that stuff for the
shutdown is part of Paramount Global's
layoff of 25 of its domestic staff this
comes amid more Hollywood turmoil and
stars taking a stand as we hit day nine
of the rider strike look out for
yourself that's grammy-winning band
Imagine Dragons outside Netflix
headquarters in La showing support for
striking Riders
[Music]
and in Queens Tina Fey Seth Meyers and
Fred Armisen were spotted marching the
three SNL alums joined other stars
who've taken to the picket line
including Rob Lowe Pete Davidson and
Cynthia Nixon the entire industry is at
a Crossroads and everybody knows it the
financial motor has to be completely
redefined we do not have scripts without
writers like minds are going to have to
come down and be Equitable so how long
could this last we know for at least
another couple of weeks the Riders will
be on strike but after that a lot of it
depends on where the studios and the
streamers come to an agreement or not in
agreement with the Director's Guild
[Music]